you should have your triangle there
here's what you're going to do with it
okay i'm going to stick mine up on the
board so that you can see it clearly
obviously you can just do this on your
table okay so i have my triangle here
i have my triangle here now what i'd
like you to do
is on your on your page right
um if yours is a bit too big for this no
big deal but if it's small enough that
you can fit it
that would be fantastic on your page i'd
like you to roughly
trace your triangle trace your triangle
like this
okay so i've traced my triangle and once
i've traced it
i try to talk about angles right so in
order to talk about them i'm going to
label them i'm going to call it a b and
c because mathematicians are very
creative like that
i'll call this one over here a
b and c okay
so you can see i've got my three angles
i've got them named
and you should name them on your actual
cardboard triangle as well
put the letters on there okay now you
can take away
the cardboard one right and what you
have created
is two triangles that are exactly the
same
same shape same size etc i'm going to
take my letters my letters
and i'm just going to put them onto my
drawn triangle as well
a and b and c
fantastic okay
now that you have done that you've got a
copy of it you now know what it looks
like and it's on your page as well
we are going to do something very sad
and we're going to
destroy our triangle here's how we're
going to do it we're going to
now you can use scissors if you like but
i kind of feel like it's more fun if you
tear it
i'm going to tear my triangle into
three pieces i want each of the pieces
to have one of the angles on it so for
instance uh c c is over here
in the corner right so if i tear it like
this
all right there you go i've got c by
itself now
as an angle right and here's a and b i
guess i'm gonna
rip it along here you can you can cut it
okay if it doesn't fit that's okay uh
you don't need this step but the next
step you will need okay so you can see
i'm now going to tear it
down the middle
okay you see what i've got i've got
three pieces now
and they each have an angle on them yep
okay
so now here's the next step if your
triangle can fit in your book
then what i'm about to do do in your
book if it doesn't fit in your book
then just do it on the table beside you
and then you can draw a picture
in your book okay here's what we're
gonna do
take each of your angles right here's a
uh i'm going to put it down so if i had
my book i'd be um
putting this on top of my book again if
you're too big just put it beside your
book there's eh
i'm going to take this is this is b but
i'm going to turn it around
so that b fits next to a right so these
are now
adjacent next to each other see that so
i've got a and then i've got b
and now i've got my last angle here
right here's c
and i'm gonna have to flip it around so
that it fits in this spot over here
okay so what have i got i can
fit c right in there just tear it
okay yep just hairs now you can see
right
i created like a random triangle
and when i put the three angles together
i hope you can see
right what have i produced i've produced
number one a straight line number two a
180 degree
angle those are both the same thing a
straight line
is 180 degrees okay you can see right
the beautiful thing is everyone pretty
much has made a different triangle
but no matter what triangle you've made
no matter how you tore it they're all
like 180
right so this is idea again thinking
back to euclid
and you could say look these shapes they
have this kind of
perfection to them they always do
certain things
it's almost like magic that they have
properties and powers that are
completely separated
from us